hi and welcome to lesson for comfort
central is starting to look like an
interesting application in addition to
user management that we introduced in
lesson two we also added data store in
lesson three now it's time to look at
data relationships and how to retrieve
data and make no mistake about it that's
a lot of moving parts with respect to
this so you better keep your eye on the
ball in addition to data relationships
and queries we will be looking at data
store consistency rules and transactions
in this lesson now it's probably a good
time to seriously start to check out the
documentation on the internet as well to
become a master of building scalable
applications let's get started shall we